[Music]
what are the foundations of your
socialism well I think all from the past
I think the well I think we'd learn from
the past and we draw from ideas of the
past we also let me also draw from newer
ideas you know we draw from the you know
I have changed my politics instance
since 2015 where because I have
encountered large numbers of young
people who come with fresh ideas with
different ways of working you know who
are much greener you know much more
interesting you know the the the way
that they will in fact in in recent
weeks the way that kids at school have
changed our understanding of the
importance of climate change okay
politics you know even had an effect on
life I have no problem with it but I
think that David's discourse which was
actually about in his view to
fundamentalisms and I you know I I that
isn't a picture of the world as it has
been you know the truth is that you know
things like you know planning I'm not
you know the state have always played a
we played an important role we do not
live in a fundamentalist capitalist
world at all you know the British state
created markets no it could it conquered
a large part of the world in order to
benefit the market it's great that was
the action of the state the state still
today you know intervenes and if you
read Mariana matric Artaud's book about
in other that what the the state has how
the state has bit has created many of
the elements of the iPhone and and don't
forgive me where is socialism in this
well I the way I see socialism is what
socialism for me is make it is it is and
which would require a fundamental change
in the way that society operates and the
economy operates
is a society in which decisions are made
for the benefit of people and not for
profit that's what that's how I feel and
I I didn't disagree with anything that
Angela said about the nature of
Perficient you see the the talking about
the past and the failures of the Soviet
Union you know is is that's David
baggage you know he grew up on the
Commons I would I've never been in the
Communist Party I've never been a
Trotsky
right I'm arguing the differences not by
the end I would yes debates from 1917 or
from the gap between the first
international and the second
international really isn't very relevant
to politics today and we young people
understand for more debates talks and
interviews subscribe today to the
Institute of Arts and ideas at IAI TV
you